a big miss field goal at the end of the
broncos texans game gave the texans a
6th consecutive win once-upon-a-time
own three now six and three on their bye
week which means the pride of macon
georgia able to spend some time here in
Los Angeles with us from the Houston
Texans ninth season in the National
Football League Pro Bowl cornerback
Kareem Jackson good to see you sir
thank you thank you good to see you as
well so how does was there a turning
point in actual moment in a game where
you realized or during a preparation of
a week after going on three that you saw
maybe this happening for your team well
as a team we kind of felt like we were
close because our those are those three
losses you know we lost about three loss
by five and lost by seven so we kind of
felt like we wanted to plays away from
you know turning those losses into wins
so now we're just you know on the
receiving end of making you know making
those plays and doing what we have to do
it in terms of executing a game plan and
you know getting stops on third down you
know just little things you know
pensions to the small details and that's
kind of you know boosted us in the right
direction so we can kind of get those
wins but in a in a locker room when your
own three I mean who is helping keep
things together we got a great group of
guys you know some great leaders and
like Tyra
JJ you know the shine and also DeAndre
you know I got a great group of guys and
it was all kind of stayed together and
you know continue to you know stay
upbeat about things and like I said I
mean it's just one or two plays here and
then we felt like we were very very
close so you know God grew a group of
guys like that you know you can you can
definitely you know get the thing turned
around and we did well I mean Tyron you
mentioned Tyrann Mathieu Kareem he's
he's new to the team suggest three
losses three games in right he he was
walking around the Texans locker room
yeah as a leader yeah definitely you
know got plays with a lot of passion you
know it brings a ton of that to the game
each and every day you know just just
this whole approach you know I mean if
you got if anybody knows tire you know
know how nobody came from you know LSU
and the things that he'd been through
guys a lot of a ton of passion and he
wears it on his sleeve so
just been around him on a day-to-day
basis he always you know very very
positive and he definitely definitely
kept you know kept everybody know
mentally you know focus on what on the
goals that we had at hand and you know
it was able to you know get some things
turned around tell me what John Watson's
like what's he like very laid-back very
laid-back
what do you mean alone he just doesn't
say much he's almost like a kid you know
he I mean obviously he's young but yes
just kind of being around him you know
he's all smiles loves to listen to music
you know about music but eat a ton of
different rap rap music you know but um
he carries yourself like he's been in a
game about ten ten or twelve years you
know in terms of preparation you know it
turns up practice and it's just being
around him is always positive energy
from him so you know I think that's
great
you know we have a quarterback like that
certainly after the years at the
revolving door that you had at that
position right all right definitely
definitely cuz seen the tiny guys come
and go but uh within games career within
games within games so ton of guys come
and go but he'll definitely it's
definitely beautiful a long time Kareem
Jackson here on the Rich Eisen show so
now six and three once upon a time oh
and three what are you guys talking
Super Bowl you know that's always the go
that's what we work towards but other
words do you actually say those words
well we just say a week at a time play
at a time week at a time you know that's
always the ultimate goal but for us we
just want to take a play at a time a
game at a time a week at a time practice
at a time and you know he's continued to
be consistent as a team well I know you
you didn't particularly pinpoint a
moment in the Texan season where things
turned around but for me as a an
observer as a viewer that Sunday night
game with Dallas mm-hmm it struck I mean
that was a hard hitting affair yeah we
all know DeSean got beat up in it but
you guys were laying the wood in that
game it just struck me right that you
looked like a different team in that
game would you agree with that I would
think so I would think so you know
one in three came off your first win of
the season in state rivalry kind of
brings something outside of you also you
know Houston versus Dallas you know he
got ton of fans you know and both sides
so I definitely definitely bring
something outside of us as a team and
you know we just wanted to go in and in
in executing and do the things that we
need to do to get a win and you know we
was able to do it it was it was a tough
hard-fought game it was able to pull
that one out also what was it like from
your vantage point watching DeAndre
Hopkins go on that overtime catch and
run to essentially win that game man
the energy is great just to see him and
the things he did that game it's kind of
scary though as a as a defensive player
sitting on the sidelines kind of
watching him and and his hands are so
big to the point where he never touched
the ball so he's just kind of running
with it you know just holding it out
he's like a loaf of bread right spin
move spin move and I'm like just hold on
to just hold onto it but that's what he
does though that's that's the type of
player he is you know he's a great
player a great receiver in this game so
I was just kind of it's a lot of fun to
sit there and watch him on a
week-to-week basis Kareem Jackson here
in the Rich Eisen show you as a
defensive unit earlier in that game were
you surprised that Dallas did not go for
it on fourth down and punted the ball
away I was a surprise who's playing some
tough defense that game so me but you
didn't think I'm in your head after that
third down okay we're gonna have to stay
out here and defend a fourth oh you like
thinking about it yeah we're definitely
gonna have to get a stop especially the
way the game was going close game you
know you know close defensive game also
he's kind of thinking you hit all right
well we definitely gonna have to get a
stop here on fourth down but you know
form the punt and you try to play field
positions and you know that's cool too
all right I'm gonna turn you into an
analyst and part of the paparazzi here
on your bye week Kareem Jackson after
the Monday night game we just saw last
night where the Titans
your competitors in the AFC South kind
of just laid it on put the bang thing on
Dallas and right in their building is
dak Prescott a franchise quarterback in
this league
I think so I think so no I mean you had
a great year last year and every year
you know brings different challenges you
know so I mean sometimes guys are gonna
struggle by at the end of the day you
know it's all about you come out you
know you come out of that hole so I'm
for him II just gotta you know go back
to work and continue to you know improve
eating every week you know that's what
it's about this that's what this league
is about so um I think so he's a dual
threat guy you know he's proving that he
can make you know all the throws on the
field so uh it's just all about standing
I didn't you let's continue to fight
well I mean in this regard because I
know you don't want to disrespect him
either I'm looking at your quarterbacks
Brady these are the guys you had to
prepare for this you all right Brady
Mariota Eli Manning Andrew Luck dak will
take Buffalo out of the equation right
now because they're I mean serious I'm
not trying to denigrate but they've got
rookies and obviously the correct
situation is a is a particular type of
fire right now then you have bortles the
Miami game was Osweiler amazing that you
had to face him and then Denver where
does dak ranked in terms of the
quarterbacks that you had to analyze
throughout the week and you were
concerned about putting your helmet and
pads on going to play a game I honestly
it's kind of tough preparing for a guy
like that because he's a dual threat guy
you know he could throw the ball and he
can run so all the 11 guys definitely
had to you know be ready to do their job
you know you got to keep him in the
pocket and you just try to make it
one-dimensional but in terms of ranking
them and as far as the guys that we've
seen this year you know obviously Brady
you know we all know what Brady what
type of guy Brady is what type of player
he is you know he's obviously you know
the number one guy but um
I'll say I mean Mariota is you know kind
of similar guys both guys been running
through so I rank those two guys right
around the same you know in my eyes
anyway because it's almost the same when
you're preparing for those guys okay so
let's talk Kareem Jackson a few more
minutes left with you sir you're from
Georgia yes you go to Alabama
yes sir okay how did that happen
cuz Nick Saban just arrived is that how
walk me through how you want
it's a wild story so I was just coming
back from a visit at Maryland and I went
to Fort Union Military Academy on high
school I was a mid meteor guy so I was
looking to enroll in college you know in
the spring so I just came back from
Maryland you know my mind I was like you
know what Marilyn hadn't started for the
spring yet so you know it's probably my
best option so I get a call that same
night I come back from Maryland it's
Coach Saban he said look we've already
started school here but I can still get
you in he had just got the job at
Alabama so I was like after Miami just
left Miami he just got the job maybe
like a week prior to this to this
conversation that I was having with him
so he's know out doing recruiting you
know he's on the road and stuff so it's
like okay I can still get you in another
thing is you know I'm gonna need you to
come you know see how you like it look
around but you got to come tomorrow so
this was I just love Marilyn Marilyn
that Sunday so I go I meet him at a
little private out port you know he's
going out recruiting and stuff and then
coach smart coach Kirby smart jumps in
the car with me and my my high school
coach end up taking me my parents had to
work that day so it's me my high school
coach and Kirby smart we drive out of
the Belma I look around and in my house
and man this is why I want to be and I
was in class the next day
so from Sunday to having a conversation
with him going to look around campus
that Monday and I was in class Tuesday
no clothes no nothing I just they just
put me in the dorm rooms what gave me a
cup of sweat suits I was in the dorm
room and then finally that weekend I
went home and got the rest of my things
and the rest is history so saving calls
you you're coming back from Maryland and
the current coach at Georgia is the one
that drove with you and your high school
coach yeah to Tuscaloosa you lay eyes in
the place say I'm coming here you're in
class with your belongings still back
home everything back home I had a cup of
sweat suits my high school coach end up
taking me to Walmart got me a little
some sheets and stuff like that for my
dorm room for toiletry items and that
was it I was in class the next day and
then you're a national champion a couple
years later national champ four-star
recruit were you yell four-star recruit
what was Sabin like is it good what was
it walk me through you the first speech
you heard from Nick was he like the what
I remember to this day he was saying he
just kept saying you know if we're gonna
do this we got to do it like and it's
gonna happen fast but it's like you know
he's kept saying it's like you know it's
gonna work out for the best you know
it's gonna be a great situation for us
and you know you're gonna have a great
chance to you know come in and compete
and get a starting job early so I came
in cuz I was able to go through spring I
was able to go through camping and I
started as a true freshman and off you
go
I'll forego how often you speak to
savings do I usually try to catch a game
maybe wants to one or two games so I
usually try to wait once they get to the
college cars football playoffs oh come
on
Kareem come on you just rolling the
footballs out huh just like that's what
you wait for
have you seen that machine I have seen I
have I just sit and watch all year and I
just you know ever they played college
football playoffs that you know I go
check a game out or I go to the national
championship last I went to the National
Champion game so that was something what
I was in news in Georgia right right
how good is to it what you seek man
knowing that you may have to defend
against him in short order cook amazing
man because we've never had this type of
firepower you know we've always had you
know the tools as far as receivers
running backs but in terms of you know
this particular quarterback who never
had a guy like tor that you know can
make every throw and the thing that's
surprising he could still run so he
hadn't had to run much but he can still
run so he hasn't had to pass much
he just needs fourth quarter past the
season rushed Saturday even though he's
he's been amazing it's been it's been
exciting to watch you know it's always
great to especially see ma ma ma to do
that especially and go to del Valle and
you know beat up on them the way they
did you know so it's exciting to watch
them
so you and Deshawn what are the
conversations you have every January
Kareem it seems like we for the most
part we just try to figure out you know
if we're gonna go to the game or not
it's mostly deandre with the trash talk
yeah I keep forgetting there's another
goat Clemson mostly hop with the trash
talking so just you know they say he's
all right now he says it's gonna be you
know Alabama and Clemson you know we
worked up on him last year so you can't
say too much now but the quarterback is
unbelievable right now too so it's gonna
be exciting it's not mean it's not that
you need any help in this department but
if you ever want to shut it down with
DeAndre or Deshawn although you tell me
Deshawn doesn't really talk much like
that so you have to shut him down he's
too nice right
he's just remind them where to dab I'll
go to school yeah and where do you think
this only the one only job dabble would
even consider thinking about flinching
in the direction of Allen college
football that's true that's true
you're welcome as truthful essentially
what I'm telling I was true before I let
you go Kareem Jackson tell me about your
foundation the work that I have a
foundation Kareem Jackson foundation and
I it benefits women with breast cancer
and kids with cancer and my mom is a
two-time breast cancer survivor my
sister is a leukemia survivor so she's
kind of growing up and seeing them go
through that you know go through that
struggle you know cancer is a terrible
disease and you know to see any family
go through it man it's tough so for me
once I kind of got in a position where I
can create my foundation you know it was
a no-brainer for me you know the benefit
you know what it was going to benefit so
on I do a couple events this year I
actually just finished the an event and
it's called dinner for different so we
raised over 200,000 well in a single
night so um it was a lot of fun it was a
great night you know
we keep a lot of things you know kind of
updated you know the things that we have
going on in cream jackson dot org is the
website you can go in there check
everything go and we got we got a ton of
stuff coming up and we just try to stay
active in the community and you know do
things and you know and like I said you
know these kids with cancer you know we
just try to do something give us some
type of stability if we can go put
smiles on their faces whatever we can do
to help them and their families and also
these women with breast cancer we
definitely you know all willing to do
that good for you Kareem Jackson Kareem
Jackson org and you are the Players
Association community service member of
the month yes yes October actions on a
front thank you really appreciate it
could cheer the whole team JJ Watt
DeSean and then of just just three
community oriented individuals the
Houston Texans at ream boy 25 did I say
that yeah properly okay REE em Bo I 25
okay on Twitter great to see you cream
Jackson I may be City stop anytime
you're in Los Angeles okay well you got
it that's Kareem Jackson here not going
to the game against Mississippi State
this weekend because it's not big enough
for him now okay right here on the Rich
Eisen show the Rich Eisen show weekdays
at noon eastern on audience